hey guys Pete peppers here and we're
going to do a candy crush jelly saga
level 56 commentary walkthrough and it's
a tough level well it's I don't know if
it's tough it's more frustrating it's
one of those levels where you you know
some chance some boards are just not set
up right so I'm going to talk about some
of the strategy and you know how to how
to get through it faster but just keep
in mind that it's gonna be toughest on
some of the tribes no matter what you do
so what we want to do is we want to kind
of keep the puffers up top so I made a
rap candy there and unfortunately it ran
down below but you know just in general
I want to keep I'm gonna keep matching
around the cakes and setting up specials
and combos and clearing out the bottom
and you know my hope is is that some of
the some of the puffers will stay up in
the top of the board when I do that so
there goes one maybe they both want up
there actually yeah so that that's
that's basically the general idea so I'm
gonna still you know even though I'm
gonna still work at the bottom and still
look for specials and I want to
definitely cut this off right here the
chance for them to go down below so we
know where they're at we don't really
need to work on the top because as you
can see you know you'll pick them up as
you go as they cascade down and I think
they're both under there right now but
in in most cases you don't know exactly
where they're at so you can see I'm
still just keeping up with my same
strategy you have moving things down and
that way I'd be able to clean it up if I
needed to
so now isn't a bad time to kind of check
out and see where they're at and I
learned that they're both up at the top
so now I can sort of change my strategy
and just free them up and so yeah
they're just a couple more matches and
they'll be free now
so the like I said it's frustrating it
can definitely sometimes when they all
go underneath the cakes it's gonna be
really tough to beat so you just you
know keep an eye out try to prep you
know trying to keep making matches down
on the bottom and if you see them go up
in the top definitely do what I did with
that striped candy which is cut off
where you know they they can't go back
down below and you know if you get one
where they're all below there then just
just try again and eventually it'll set
up for you and you'll be able to save
all three puffers so I hope this helps
definitely leave any questions if you
have them below like the video please
and subscribe to my channel to get more
how-to and walkthrough videos see you
soon